ED GLAESER: In the 21st century speak the words,
city and you conjure images of skyscrapers.
Great urban skylines ARE forests of tall steel framed buildings.
Super tall structures, like the Burj Khalifa in Dubai,
or the Petronas Towers in Kuala Lumpur, are
used to announce the emergence of a city on the global stage.
But for millennia, we had cities without tall towers.
Europe is still dotted with major metropolises,
such as Rome, that are almost completely without skyscrapers.
The skyscraper's invention in the late 19th century
is itself an example of how cities can solve their own problems by allowing
collaborative chains of creativity.
For thousands of years, the Great Pyramid of Giza
was the world's tallest structure standing
as a monument to the coercive powers of the pharaohs,
as well as to Egyptian engineering.
But finally in the 14th century, church spires
began to push above its 481 foot height.
Lincoln Cathedral in England may have reached 525 feet in 1311.
But its tall wooden spire was demolished by a violent storm
during the turbulent reign of Edward the Sixth.
After its destruction, the global height record
was held by a series of church towers.
St. Mary's in Strassland, Strasbourg, St. Nikolai
in Hamburg, Notre Dame in Rouen, and finally Cologne,
which was only completed in 1880, and soon lost its preeminence
to the Washington Monument.
And then the towering Eiffel Tower, which
soared 300 meters above Paris, vastly higher than any earlier building.
The Eiffel Tower's wrought iron structure points
to a central engineering element of the skyscraper.
A steel or cast iron skeleton that bears the weight of the building.
Indeed, a reasonable view is that the skyscraper
can be defined as a tall-ish building, perhaps with at least 10 stories,
with elevators and a metal frame.
This definition emphasizes that the skyscraper
depended on combining two 19th century technologies, high quality metal
production, and safe elevators.
Metal had been used in building for over a millenium.
The Chinese, who were master metalworkers,
produced cast iron pagodas in the seventh century.
But before the Industrial Revolution, metal
was expensive and uneven in quality.
In fact, one reason why James Watt moved from Glasgow
to make his separate condenser steam engines,
was that he needed high quality metal cylinders, which
could be supplied in Birmingham from the nearby furnaces of the legendary John
Iron Mad Wilkinson.
Great innovations regularly require collaboration,
which is why cities like Watt's Birmingham,
have so often been hubs of invention.
The Industrial Revolution powered by Watt's steam engines,
turned high quality iron into a plausible building material.
Wilkinson himself played a major role in building the world's first cast iron
bridge.
William Strutt built textile mills with wooden beams
that were encased by sheet iron to reduce the risk of fires.
Charles Bage did him one better by building the Ditherington Flax
Mill with an entirely iron frame.
This may be the world's first iron frame building and a proto skyscraper.
An iron frame means that the weight of the building is borne not by the walls,
but by a metal skeleton.
The facade is hung like a sheet on this underlying frame.
So while traditional mass wall construction
requires unbelievably thick walls, or perhaps flying
buttresses to support great height, framed buildings
can have thin light walls, even walls of glass,
since the skeleton is actually holding up the structure.
Consequently metal frame buildings became particularly popular
for uses that benefit from light.
A.T. Stewart was one of New York's greatest merchants,
and his salesmanship made him one of the richest men in history.
He realized that displaying merchandise on the ground floors of his stores
would lure in New York City's heavy pedestrian traffic.
And so he built his 1848 marble palace with big windows facing the street.
The windows made the ground floor was weak,
and to hold up the rest of the structure his architect
used cast iron columns for support.
In 1862, Stewart brought in even more light with his iron palace built
with a complete cast iron skeleton.
Windows are even more useful in greenhouses,
which is why Joseph Paxton, a towering figure in Victorian horticulture,
became an artist when he built with cast iron.
Paxton won the competition to build a home
for London's Great Exhibition of 1851.
His crystal palace was another precursor to the skyscraper,
and it encompassed almost one million square feet, with 4,000 tons of iron,
and 900,000 square feet of glass.
Paxton would influence other architects, like Victor Baltard, who
used cast iron to build Paris' central market, Les Halles,
and the iron beam supported church of St. Augustine.
New York built its own crystal palace in 1853.
And the next year, Elijah Otis dazzled the crowds within its walls.
He stood high on an elevator and ordered the rope holding it to be cut.
His fall was almost immediately broken by the safety catch
that Otis had designed.
Otis' elevators made it safe to move vertically.
And in 1870, New York's iron framed Equitable Life Assurance building
rose to 130 feet, and became the first office building to offer elevators.
High floors had been tough to rent because tenants
disliked walking up all those stairs.
Otis changed all that, and unleashed the commercial possibilities
of building up.
Architectural historians have often referred
to Chicago's Home Insurance Building, built in 1884,
as the world's first skyscraper.
And its architect William Le Baron Jenney,
has often been called the father of the skyscraper.
But naturally, there's a lively architectural history
debate about this Home Insurance only has steel framing on the outer walls.
Moreover, home insurance is only eight feet taller
than New York's earlier Equitable Building,
although it does have 10 rather than seven stories.
But the Montauk Building, erected a few years earlier than Home Insurance
by Daniel Burnham and John Root, also had 10 stories.
Burnham and Root would build Chicago's towering 21
story Masonic temple a few years later.
Burnham would also bring the innovations of the Chicago school
into New York with his Flat Iron building.
Maybe Burnham or Root are the real fathers of the skyscraper.
Or maybe Louis Sullivan, whose architectural vision
imagined skyscrapers that fully embraced the potential of the steel frame,
or maybe Peter B. White, the great fireproofing engineer,
really deserves the credit.
I think that the search for any single father of the skyscraper
is actually a fool's errand, for the skyscraper,
like pretty much every other great human invention, is a collaborative creation.
All of these Chicago architects knew each other.
Sullivan and Burnham both worked as apprentices for Jenney.
They all liberally borrowed ideas from one another.
Jenney made a first step that relied heavily
on even earlier innovations from Birmingham to New York.
And the others riffed on his start.
If anything, the city of Chicago deserves the credit,
for it assembled a remarkable collection of architectural talent
to rebuild after its great fire.
That talent, connected by urban density collaboratively
figured out how to make buildings that soared, and that soared beautifully.
The skyscraper is a reminder of how cities solve their own problems.
In this case the need to fit more usable space on a finite amount of land
by enabling smart people to learn from one another.